I have a question for you now
so before last week I think maybe was
when I was with Stu but I I shared this
anecdote or this this sort of advice
which was if you're offered to see it on
a rocket ship
you know don't ask which seat just sit
down and buckle up and this is just
career advice which is if you're not
gonna start your own cup for it did I
yeah I thought people loved it what do
you mean well but what was what was the
criticism based on and wasn't even
controversial just stuff like titles it
was just comments like people saying
titles are important how much we get
paid is more important things like that
that's crazy
disagree hard disagree okay so anyways
the question was sort of that led to a
different caution which is what are the
rocket ships of today and so somebody by
the way took that idea and made of
rocket ship newsletter for jobs or
whatever but beyond that I was just sort
of thinking just my thought experiment
what companies that today are worth 1 to
5 billion do I believe will be multi
hundred billion so what's it just as a
way of phrasing it simpler what five
billion dollar company today could
become a five hundred billion dollar
company in the future I say this because
we have friends who bought Facebook
secondary stock back in 2006 and 2007
when Facebook was valued at over a
billion dollars and today Facebook's
like whatever five hundred billion
dollar company and that you know it was
clear it wasn't going to see Rove it was
clear it was a thing and the question
but you could have invested then and got
a phenomenal return and I have several
friends of it I had a friend Alex oh no
sorry Josh Buckley who's a good guy
founder and British guy British guy he's
and so he he was telling me we were just
hanging out one day he's like yeah I'm
buying secondary stock of stripe as much
as I can get and I was like what do you
mean like I'm not doing that why are you
doing that I should do that and he was
like yeah I just think stripes a great
company and there's secondary stock
available and I'm just buying it I'm
like well what's the valuation it's
already like a two billion dollar
company he's like yeah but it's like
Sharp's gonna be big you think I think
stripes gonna be huge so I'm just buying
up secondary
and now so stripes Valley bound like 20
billion dollars so he took essentially
like a no-risk pet in my opinion and 10x
his money on a private company that was
it was already a unicorn but wasn't yet
on the stock market it wasn't doing like
10% a year you know that's a 10x
appreciation so long story short what
companies do you think have that
potential that are in the single-digit
billions today or less that you think
could be a Facebook Google Amazon of our
generation so a few years ago I answered
this question and I thought it was
Atlassian and I went in on that and I
and it worked okay tell me about that
what do you mean it worked back then it
was you just look look go ahead and
relook going on a laughingstock you're
busy today I invested it last thing in
stock I mean sound like I like yeah I'd
let Atlassian spelled with an eighty
eighty there it is yeah and then go to
all-time I bought at laugh max on the
far right I bought it when it when it
went public so what did it go up by it's
like a 3x already so I 3x my money so I
bought a glass e'en because I read their
annual report I was like oh these guys
are great right their market caps now 35
billion yeah so I bought it right when
it went out so that worked so what do
you think and get to the over a hundred
billion it's very hard to get over a
hundred billion how many companies are
worth over 100 billion like very very
few especially if you think about tech
companies so some of the tech companies
that made it Amazon made it Google made
it Microsoft made it Facebook made it
uber did not quite make it yet but it's
getting there Tesla made it like I think
I invested in Tesla when it was at about
this number five five to eight billion
oh really and now it's almost 100
billion and so like that so that's a big
lift of a company that it's out there
it's not a seed same startup you're
taking a bet on right it's a company
that's out there and the other way to
take the bet on it even if you're not an
investor just to go work at one of these
companies right so like Airbnb was a
good candidate
now it's valued too high to qualify for
this Airbnb is like it I don't know 35
billion or something like that we'll see
it what happens with this but it's not
in a single-digit billions anymore but
when we when we moved to San Francisco
we could have done that right when I
moved as happens you apply had a job
offer at Airbnb when it was worth
billion 1 billion maybe less I don't
know there was only knows less it was
dozen 12
right so so let's just say was that a
billion which it wasn't but let's say it
was yeah would have made 10 million oh
so it's 35 X so even if you had just
gotten a sort of standard stock package
which was like over four years you're
gonna get 200 great I would've made five
or ten million dollars yeah
that's insane and I got fired before I
even showed up to work so some other
candidates that I put up here flex port
I think is a candidate maybe Messiah
Intel that sounded like a juicy maybe
well Ryan told me he thinks it's gonna
be massive or to go bankrupt which is
like how you gonna be when you that's
how you some other this was harder than
I thought I also tweeted this out so the
most popular answers I got was air table
in Carta and I pretty much disagree with
both of those I don't know under a and I
asked these are smart people replying
and I was like Carter why card
we should get Carter response to this
podcast by the way yeah why are they not
I don't know you guys see a sponsor and
I'm gonna I don't give a about
people sponsor I'm gonna tell you the
truth Carter it's the best option out
there but it still needs a lot to
improve right I use it I give you guys
five grand a year I'm happy that I give
you the money but it can improve yeah so
air table air table it would have to
basically replace Excel in the corporate
world for it to do this otherwise it
will not be a hundred billion dollar
company
how about gussto Gusto's a good one so I
think there's a lot that are in the sort
of either HR tech just you need to be a
huge spotlight dust oh and rippling ya
go so rippling I think I would be 100
billions a high bar but yeah so other
ones that I put up here so stripe but
it's past this point
so coinbase only if the big if bitcoin
actually becomes like if bitcoin
actually is the thing it becomes the
global reserve currency then well it
doesn't have the largest bitcoin sort of
company the large bitcoin brand would be
i think it just become Bank of America
can become Wells Fargo yeah I think
Bitcoin has to become that relevant for
coin bits to be yeah I buy that open
doors another one just because
residential real estate is so big so if
they actually have a working model they
could become a hundred billion dollar
company I don't buy that because what
cuz Zillow and Trulia aren't that huge
high they don't do what these guys do
though Zillow and Trulia they sell leads
to brokers they're now trying to copy
open doors and now they offer what
cookin door offers
but open doors literally buying and
selling the houses they're flipping
houses at scale which is pretty crazy
what else this was tough I know that's
all I had but I put this on here I
wasn't gonna talk about it initially but
I'm like I want to bring this up I want
people to tell me what I'm wrong about
what companies I should be considering
in this but I think it's a really
important question because for me I'm
gonna go try to buy secondary stock and
all these company okay so I don't and if
you're working you should go work at one
of these companies one hundred billion
is that's impossible I won't even try
I'm gonna try to predict that because
like only like a few hundred people I'll
feel a few hundred businesses have ever
probably done that I don't know the
number but that's really hard to say
but if I had to make a prediction I do
think that there will be some new search
engines and I also think that some of
the new chrome replacements could be
quite large so brave is one of them
what's another one I'm placing the
browser yeah anything that are replacing
browsers I think are kind of cool and
could potentially be that big I think
there's gonna be a lot of browser I
think if any company nails AR they will
they will be able to do this but that's
not ways away I believe how about a
zoosk Suk's self-driving car company
yeah yeah so that was the other I I
considered all the self-driving car
companies cuz I'm like if if one of them
becomes a success a self a successful
self-driving car company the market
leader will be worth over a hundred
billion it's just more likely I believe
is more likely to be Tesla or one of the
incumbents rather they'll buy one of
these companies rather than that company
independently going from where it is
today which is 1 billion two hundred
billion how about this what companies
are public now that could grow that much
so I was talking to Moyes the other day
and we were looking at stamps.com
you know crazy undervalued and the next
day we were like let's buy this the next
day we didn't buy in time it went up 50%
went up 50% it was coincidental just saw
interesting stat over the last 10 years
if you just brought bought the fang
companies so Facebook Amazon Apple
Google in the 10 years it outperformed
all VCS or sorry it I'll perform even
this sort of top
expected returns of venture capital so
the public market if you just bought the
five most popular tech stocks you did
better as a twenty twenty four percent
IRR over ten years okay well what what's
public now that could I don't
know that's a great question it's that's
hard you got a really bet on industries
[Music]